corona sprechstunde mit euren fragen zur
pandemie und heute wenden wir uns wieder
der wissenschaft zu allerdings nicht dem
virus an sich der virologie sondern der
großen frage wieso die wissenschaft zur
zeit eigentlich zum ganz verschiedenen
erkenntnissen und ratschlägen kommt vor
um die sachen sich teilweise
widersprechen und was sie über mögliche
zukunftsszenarien sagt was könnte nach
corona kommen wird das virus die welt
verändern bzw was hat es heute schon
verändert dass man besprechen mit euch
euren fragen und wer könnte uns da
besser zur seite stehen als unser thx
moderator und zdf
wissenschaftsjournalist harald lesch
eure fragen an ihn bitte in die
kommentare und da ist er auch schon
hallo herr resch genannt also ja die
große frage die viele sich stellen
zurzeit ist warum kommt wissenschaft
geradezu so ganz verschiedenen
erkenntnissen zu anderen empfehlungen
also da man kommt ja gar nicht mehr aus
ohne wissenschaft zur zeit aber da heißt
es mal
man soll ibuprofen nehmen man soll es
nicht nehmen man sollen die atemmaske
aufsetzen man sollte keine art und maske
aufsetzen
woran liegt das naja es gibt erst mal so
ein grundkonsens ist ja schon da das
alles was getan wird wird getan um das
gesundheitssystem zu schonen damit es
also in der lage ist unsere schwer
erkrankten auch tatsächlich zu behandeln
man muss erst mal zur kenntnis nehmen
das ist eine zivilisatorische groß
leistung der wir hier bei wohnen dass
wir nämlich alles tun um unseren schwer
erkranken tatsächlich die möglichkeit zu
geben auch perfekt behandelt zu werden
also dass man vorab und ich glaube da
gibt es auch gar keinen dissenz unter
den epidemiologen genauso wenig wie
unter den virologen und wenn es dann
darum geht diese nicht pharmazeutischen
maßnahmen durchzuführen also
quarantänemaßnahmen ich glaube da gibt
es ein ganz ganz großen konsens aber
dann kommt eben natürlich der nächste
schritt ist was könnte man denn tun um
sich jetzt schon mal persönlich oder
insgesamt auch tatsächlich zu helfen es
gibt ja noch keine medikamente gegen das
virus es gibt auch keine impfung also
fängt man an und diskutiert dieses und
jenes und ich glaube man sollte sich vor
allen dingen momentan tatsächlich vor
allen dingen an die offiziellen stimmen
hand halten nämlich das robert koch
institut die charité zum beispiel also
oder herr kekilli in aus halle und viele
andere
prominente virologin virologen aus
deutschland die sie haben ja schon eine
sehr eine sehr starke einheitliche
meinung der variationen geben
aber es gibt natürlich im internet da
gibt es alles und alles mögliche an
scheinbar wissenschaftlichen oder auch
weniger wissenschaftlichen einlassungen
und die sollte man sagen wir mal man
kann sie ja lesen aber man sollte sie am
ende doch ignorieren wir sehen ja die
globale antwort auf dieses virus kann
nur heißen nicht pharmazeutische
interventionen kann nur heißen
quarantäne bleiben sie zu hause halten
sie die füße ruhig und ich glaube da
sind sich alle leute einig die auf dem
mit das heißt also es gibt den eindruck
da gäbe es wissen verschiedene
verschiedene perspektiven aber in
wirklichkeit so würde ich sagen ist das
nicht so aber innerhalb der
verschiedenen virologischen disziplinen
oder auch innerhalb der virologen gibt
es jedoch unterschiede uns auch
unterschiedliche diskussions ansätze
etwa zum beispiel sehr verwundert als
die whu zuerst sagte ibuprofen ist kein
problem
dann hieß es einer tage lang ist es doch
ist es doch ein problem und dann wurde
dann zurückgerudert wie kommt denn sowas
zustande
na ja das ist eine gute frage denn im
grunde genommen ist es ja so dass diese
diese ganze pandemie läuft noch gar
nicht lange genug um jetzt bereits daten
haben zu können was denn nun besonders
gut oder was besonders schlecht
funktioniert denn für jede gute daten
auch nah wir brauchen eine gute
statistik und die statistiken reichen
häufig lange nicht aus um derartig
deutlich zu sagen ibuprofen ist ganz
schlecht oder ibuprofen ist überhaupt
ist völlig harmlos in dem zusammenhang
solange man da keine eindeutigen
aussagen machen kann sollte man sie
lieber ganz stoppen weil das
verunsichert leute und diese
verunsicherung die kann als stress sogar
unser immunsystem so sehr schwächen das
ist dann eher besser ist etwas nicht zu
wissen hat sozusagen zwei
unterschiedliche meinungen beim thema
schutzmasken ist es das gleiche ich bin
ganz ehrlich auch ein bisschen
überrascht darüber dass die offiziellen
organisationen da so ablehnend sind denn
nach meinem dafürhalten ist zum beispiel
so ein land wie japan ein super beispiel
dafür warum gibt es in japan zu geringe
infektionszahlen eine so geringe
sterberate bei einer bevölkerung die in
der alterspyramide doch deutlich in die
70er und 80er jahre drängt das heißt es
gibt eine starke eine große ältere
bevölkerung und zugleich hat man die
ballungszentren also man würde erwarten
dass in japan
die infektionszahlen er nach oben gehen
und auch die sterberate hoch ist genau
das gegenteil ist der fall warum laut
einem focus -bericht nutzen die japaner
bereits ohne corona virus 5,5 milliarden
schutzmasken pro jahr das sind 43 pro
person im jahr
und warum es nicht nicht um sich vor den
anderen zu schützen sondern die anderen
vor sich zu schützen hätten wir alle
gesichtsmasken auf zumindestens in den
bereichen wo wir weniger als ein meter
fünfzig abstand halten können bin ich
mir ganz sicher hätte das einen
wesentlichen erfolg aber die offizielle
aussage ist immer die schutzmasken sind
nicht so wichtig es könnte sein dass das
auch eine traditions- frage ist denn die
asiatischen länder südkorea singapur
japan und so weiter bei denen das masken
tragen sozusagen tradition hat die haben
damit überhaupt kein problem
das wäre eine solche nicht
pharmazeutische maßnahme unter wunder
ich mich auch tatsächlich ein bisschen
über die über die unterschiedlichen
gebräuche und unterschiedliche
empfehlungen aber das ist ja genau so
eine sache die doch verunsichert weil
wir erwarten ja von wissenschaft und
gerade für organisationen wie der whu
dass man verlässliche aussagen trifft
sie sagten gerade es ist im grunde zu
früh weil wir viele zahlen noch nicht
haben weil wir viele studien noch nicht
wirklich verlässlich haben dass man
sagen kann diese haben wirklich ein
großer datenbasis ist dass etliche
aspiranten uns jetzt gewöhnen müssen wir
sind quasi mittendrin in einer
entwicklung und können eigentlich noch
nicht wirklich sagen was dann passiert
das heißt diese unsicherheit die müssen
wir jetzt mit einkalkulieren immer noch
daran gewöhnen so ist es genau das ist
das problem
wir sind es ja gewohnt über risiken zu
reden wenn wir die regeln kennen also
über den casino reingehen dann wissen
wir mit einer gewissen
wahrscheinlichkeit haben wir eine chance
in gewinn zu machen weil wir die regeln
kennen und weil wir mit
wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung hier
tatsächlich voran kommt aber in der
ungewissheit zu entscheiden ist ein
großes problem und da gibt es in der
risikoforschung durchaus den einfachen
vorschlag in ungewissheit entscheiden
das bedeutet vor allen dingen einfache
lösungen anzustreben die man schnell
wieder korrigieren kann
das heißt nicht die komplexen die
komplizierten lösungen anstreben sondern
einfache lösungen schnell überprüfen ob
das funktioniert und wenn es
funktioniert hat den nächsten schritt zu
machen das heißt schrittweise sich in
die ungewissheit vortasten daran müssen
wir uns gewöhnen
und ich finde dass zumindest hier in
deutschland aber insgesamt in europa
finde ich die maßnahme eigentlich im
großen und ganzen sehr gelungen muss ich
sagen natürlich es ist man sie
in welchen ländern es zu spät reagiert
worden ist aber gerade hier in
deutschland muss ich sagen ist insgesamt
die reaktionszeit war kurz die
interventionen sind klar deutlich sind
auch klar transportiert und klar
kommuniziert und insofern wäre jetzt
eigentlich der nächste oder ein
möglicher nächster schritt einer
einfachen maßnahme wäre möglichst vielen
menschen zu empfehlen in den situationen
wo sie ein meter fünfzig nicht einhalten
können schutzmasken zu tragen eine nicht
pharmazeutische intervention wäre das
natürlich also und immer wieder darauf
zu darauf zu schauen
alle die jetzt in dieser in dieser phase
mit uns zusammen sind wir stehen alle
vor neuland wir haben natürlich
virologischen know-how wir haben
epidemiologisch know how das handelt
aber von pandemien oder epidemien die
sind vorbei wir sitzen jetzt in der
situation die ganz neu ist und da müssen
wir natürlich auch immer sehen ob das
was passiert einen entsprechenden
positiven erfolg hat herr wieler hat
heute davon gesprochen vom robert koch
institut das sich offenbar die
infektionen verlangsamen gute nachricht
aber noch lange keine entwarnung um
gottes willen er hat es dort weiter fünf
betten nicht reichen hatte auch gesagt
genau genau das heißt man sieht es gibt
ganz unterschiedliche bereiche in diesem
in diesem thema und dieses thema ist so
groß so komplex und auch so so so
vernetzt miteinander dass man einfach
schlicht und ergreifend wie auch als
bevölkerung einfach geduld haben müssen
und auch ein bisschen geduld haben
müssen mit denjenigen die die
entscheidung treffen
das ist nämlich irgendwann ist mal so
offen sagen darf ich möchte nicht in der
haut unserer regierung steckt - uns eine
richtig schwierige sache und wir sollten
alle da ein bisschen ruhiger bleiben
ball flachhalten stabile seitenlage bund
60 würde das ist tatsächlich ganz
spannend was sie sagen also wir merken
halt auch in unseren gesprächen mit den
verschiedenen experten die wir führen
dass verschiedene argumente da gebracht
werden wir haben diese woche mit dem
virologen ich mit china sieht vom aus
hamburg gesprochen vom müssen sie mich
kurz nicht helfen es nicht gewesen
sondern das institut für tropenmedizin
genau
und der hat gesagt atemmasken können die
menschen in falscher sicherheit wiegen
auch da müssen wir also ganz genau
hinschauen wie dir was benutzen und ich
glaube das ist tatsächlich etwas was
viele menschen gerade verunsichert ich
habe einen kommentar von silvia dicker
auf facebook die man das wird so viel
geredet und jeder hat eine meinung auf
einen nenner kommen wir alle nicht
hauptsache die bevölkerung
ängstigen und verrückt machen das heißt
da tatsächlich müssen wir auch schauen
dass wir auch als medienmacher
wahrscheinlich nicht zu viel berichten
oder nicht zu viel unterschiedliches
berichten oder immer wieder einordnen
wie gehen wir damit am besten um
sie wissen jetzt mal sehen was für einen
zeitraum wir schon jetzt haben also wir
haben ja wie viele minuten sendezeit
sind in öffentlich rechtlichen im
privaten medien im internet jetzt
verwendet worden um über das corona
virus zu berichten
das ist ja eine eine unglaubliche welle
an informationen und das immer wieder in
zusammenhang zu bringen mit dem was es
gerade neues gibt das alte hinter sich
lassen das neue wieder aufnehmen und so
weiter das ist ja eine unglaubliche wie
soll ich sagen mediale belastung für
unsere hirne normalerweise sind wir es
gewohnt doch relativ stabile
verhältnisse um uns herum zu haben die
mögen sich leicht variieren mögen leicht
variieren aber im großen und ganzen
bleiben die dinge doch wie sie sind
deswegen sind mir solche business as
usual wesen
wir haben es gerne wenn es stabil ist es
mag durchaus ein bisschen variieren aber
nicht zu sehr
und jetzt sitzen wir doch in der
situation mal ganz ehrlich das ist doch
eine fallhöhe in aus der wir da herunter
gekommen sind und praktisch auf null
abgebremst worden sind das ist doch
ungeheuerlich dass haben ja noch noch
nie erlebt so was also ich hab ich
erinnere mich noch daran vor ein paar
wochen haben wir doch über tempolimit
auf der autobahn gesprochen jetzt haben
wir das tempo null was für eine
abbremsung das heißt wir sind in einer
situation die ist für alle ungewohnt und
ich finde es erstaunlich wie
diszipliniert die bevölkerung ist wie
ruhig alle sind es gibt wird nach wie
vor sehr sehr viel gott sei dank
kommuniziert aber es wird ruhig
kommuniziert mal abgesehen von so ein
paar augen die immer wieder da hektik
hineinbringen wollen aber es geht darum
wirklich ruhig zu handeln das geht im
grunde genommen darum wie wie gute
medizinerinnen und mediziner bei einem
notfall agieren hat sich anschauen was
ist der fall
was haben wir mit den mitteln arbeiten
mit dem wir uns gerade zur verfügung
stehen und dann schrittweise eins nach
dem anderen vorzugehen
und wenn es nötig ist auch mal den mut
zu haben zu unpopulären entscheidungen
und darum wird es gehen und letzten
endes ist gerade die notfall metapher
ist vielleicht ein guter punkt weil bei
einem notfall verschwindet der kalender
da verschwindet der terminplan da ändert
sich alles schlagartig und wenn man sich
mal überlegt welche heiligen kühe wir in
den letzten zwei wochen oder letzten
drei wochen in deutschland alles schon
geschlachtet
haben das wäre doch undenkbar gewesen
vorher die verbote die
verzichtserklärung die gemacht worden
sind also alles was wir momentan sehen
ist auch für uns eine völlig neue
situation und das verängstigt das
verunsichert und umso wichtiger es ist
wirklich ruhig zu bleiben hier handelt
es sich nicht wie ein whu mitglied
neulich noch einmal ganz deutlich gesagt
hat es geht nicht um eine zombie
apokalypse viele leute denken hier in
weltuntergänge es geht hier nicht um
einen um einen massen um ein
massensterben wir haben es mit einer
ernst zu nehmenden pandemie zu tun
wir sind erst am anfang wie wir immer
wieder hören und wir tun das alles um
unser gesundheitssystem in dem zustand
zu behalten der es möglich macht auch
große zahlen von schwer erkrankten neben
all den anderen schwer erkranken so zu
behandeln dass wir sicher sein können
wir tun wir bieten ihnen das beste was
wir können und das finde ich muss ich
noch mal sagen einfach eine absolute
zivile groß leistung dass das so ist und
das sollte uns alle ziemlich stolz
machen dass wir uns dazu durchgerungen
haben dass unsere repräsentanten sich
dazu durchringt und dass das eigentlich
in allen ländern so ist das finde ich
also vom standpunkt eines außerirdischen
betrachtet würde ich sagen macht die
menschheit gerade einen echten sprung
nach vorne da gucken wir dann noch mal
drauf was der sprung nach vorne sein
könnte und die zukunftsszenarien
erstmal müssen wir ja feststellen so
richtig völlig neu ist das was wir
gerade erleben nicht weil es gab ja
schon mal große epidemien weltweit und
wissenschaftler haben auch immer wieder
gewarnt dass so etwas wieder kommen
könnte tatsächlich auch in einer
größenordnung wie er selbst erleben denn
der mensch tut sein übriges dazu wir
haben den wildtieren ihren lebensraum
sie kommen immer näher an uns heran und
dann passiert eben das oder das kann das
passieren was hier mutmaßliches passiert
ist nina niebergall erklärt dass das
ganze mal genauer
tiere die da auftauchen wo menschen
nicht mehr auf die straße dürfen wie
diese schleichkatzen indien als würde
sie sich einen teil ihres lebensraums
zurückerobern lebensraum den wir
menschen hektar weise zerstören und
dadurch zur verbreitung von solchen
beitragen die von tieren auf menschen
übertragen werden das sagen
wissenschaftler seit jahren jahrzehnten
und jetzt auch die
bundesumweltministerin je mehr der
mensch die natur zerstört desto größer
ist das risiko dass der virus
überspringt und desto größer ist das
risiko eines krankheitsausbruchs bis hin
eben zu einer pandemie
schon seit 2006 mahnen wissenschaftler
mindestens 70% menschlicher
infektionskrankheiten sind zwei dosen
wurden also von tieren auf menschen
übertragen von nutztieren etwa die
schweinegrippe aber vor allem von
wildtieren meer stammt vermutlich von
dromedaren hiv von schimpansen und ebola
von fledermäusen damit kennt sich
heribert hofer aus er ist direktor am
berliner leibniz institut für zoo und
wildtierforschung
die zerstörung von lebensräumen ist
deshalb ein problem weil auf diese weise
wir als menschen in neue lebensräume
vordringen und dort dann begegnungen mit
wildtierarten haben die bisher mit uns
nicht in kontakt standen
ein beispiel die herstellung von palmöl
plantagen anzulegen hat indonesien drei
viertel seiner wälder gerodet vertreibt
damit auch fledermäuse die lassen sich
in malaysia auf obstbäumen nieder und
bringen das gefährliche virus mit 70
prozent der infizierten menschen sterben
es ist nicht nur so dass china oder in
afrika was getan werden muss sondern bis
es ein problem was wir auch mit auslösen
und das was wir hier an soja an palmöl
hereinholen führt in anderen ländern
eben zur deutlichen naturzerstörung und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass was wir
wissen jetzt auch in handeln umzusetzen
svenja schulze verspricht maßnahmen zu
erarbeiten für zoologe heribert hofer
ist schon jetzt klar wir müssen zu einer
nachhaltigen form des wirtschafts
wirtschaftens kommen und eine
nachhaltige lebensführung kommen es
bedeutet nicht unbedingt dass wir auf
wohlstand verzichten müssen das bedeutet
aber dass er den raubbau den wir immer
noch betreiben an noch relativ
unberührten lebensräumen verringern
es wird weitere pandemien geben da sind
sich wissenschaftler einig wie viele es
werden das haben wir ein stück weit
selbst in der hand
großes thema darüber sprechen wir heute
über corona wissenschaft und die welt
danach mit unserem zdf
wissenschaftsjournalisten harald lesch
und thx moderator so jetzt haben wir
hier habe ich hier schon so ein paar
kommentare gelesen ich hoffe die
menschheit entwickelt sich endlich zum
guten und gabriele meint wir können also
ohne die working together we can zu
werden können das ganze nur zusammen
schaffen und dieses große thema umwelt
und corona bewegt viele menschen
wenn man sich das aber so anguckt helle
davor warnen wissenschaftler seit jahren
sie wissen was da passieren kann und die
rennen trotzdem sehnen auch es in so
eine katastrophe wie kann denn sowas
sein
fast hätte ich gesagt gute frage nächste
frage
das ist natürlich eine ganz das ist ein
riesen komplex es ist ja nicht so dass
die politik prinzipiell wurde auch die
ökonomie politik nicht ansprechbar ist
gegenüber wissenschaften nur handelt es
sich dabei zumeist eben um
volkswirtschaft oder und
betriebswirtschaft es geht dann schlicht
um die wissenschaften bei denen es sich
ums geld dreht
es wird relativ selten rücksicht darauf
genommen dass es auf die
naturwissenschaften die immer wieder
angeben moment unser planet ist eine
endliche kugel da kann es nicht platz
beliebig platz geben das heißt wenn wir
uns ausbreiten dann kommen wir nicht nur
der natur näher sondern die natur kommt
auch uns näher
das bedeutet wir üben evolution druck
aus auf die ökologische systeme dort und
die üben natürlich entsprechend ihrer
anpassungsmöglichkeiten dann auch druck
auf uns aus aber das sind alles
zusammenhänge die oft in dem
ökonomischen business as usual szenario
eben dann tatsächlich verloren gehen man
darf nicht vergessen unsere
gesellschaften sind darauf aufgebaut
dass sie sich stabilisieren durch
ständiges wachstum
wir können wie man sieht es ja auch
aktuell wenn man bei den firmen mal nach
schaut die haben alle in den letzten 20
25 jahren am sehr viele firmen sehr
große gewinne in anführungsstrichen
realisiert aber das sind keine der iss
sind keine vorräte angelegt worden
sondern es ist gewachsen sondern man hat
kredite aufgenommen und so weiter das
führt jetzt dazu dass in relativ kurzer
zeit große unternehmen von denen man bis
jetzt immer nur
solche superzahlen gehört hat die
brauchen jetzt geld fragt man sich ihrem
ersten moment moment mal habt doch in
den letzten jahren so wahnsinnig viel
geld verdient wo ist denn das alles hin
das heißt wir sehen hier jetzt auch die
schwachstellen eines auf shareholder
value zum beispiel ausgelegten globalen
kapitalismus kann man einfach so sagen
wo es nicht nur darum geht das alles
just in time is also dass sie dass man
keine lagerhaltung er hat auch ein
ausdruck dafür dass man keine vorräte
mehr anlegt sondern dass alles auf
durchfluss angelegt ist und in diesem
durchfluss szenario nämlich dass es
wirklich ständig weiter gehen muss und
ständig wachsen muss ist natürlich die
natur als eine konstante als die
bedingung der möglichkeit überhaupt auf
diesem planeten sein zu können ist immer
eine störung ich meine man muss sich mal
klar machen damit ökonomie funktioniert
also damit auch leute in die zukunft
investieren ist die gesundheit ja die
voraussetzung dafür
wenn wir alle ständig befürchten müssten
dass wir morgen an irgendeiner
katastrophalen pandemie erkranken oder
also irgend einem virus erkrankt oder
sowas dann wären unsere ökonomischen
entscheidungen nicht so langfristig also
das heißt das system das die ganze zeit
davon gelebt hat dass der staat das die
staaten für die gesundheit ihrer bürger
sorgt lebt natürlich genau davon dass
die menschen gesund sind oder gesund
guard sich auch gesund halten können
durch zum beispiel ein gesundheitswesen
wie unseres und das ist ganz eigenartig
dass also auf der einen seite diese
merkwürdigkeit da ist wir achten im
grunde genommen auf unsere persönliche
gesundheit aber das ökonomische system
nimmt darauf keine rücksicht und es
nimmt auch keine rücksicht auf die
gesundheit der umwelt denn wenn die
natur gesund ist dann ist auch der
mensch gesund wie so schön heißt wenn
man also mal den organismus erde so oder
die erde als organismus nimmt dann merkt
man ganz deutlich wie wichtig es wäre
wenn wir nicht von umwelt sprechen
würden sondern von mit welt da also
schon unser sprachgebrauch hat es also
ein anderer aber die menschen sind ja
also die menschen mit denen wir zusammen
leben die nennen wir nie ungewohnt
sondern mitbewohner weil wir mit ihnen
zusammenleben weil wir auch wissen wie
wir voneinander abhängig sind aber wir
haben noch nicht wirklich über rissen in
der ökonomie auch in der globalen
ökonomie nicht wie wichtig die
natürlichen bedingungen und wie wichtig
diese bedingung die voraussetzungen
dafür sind dass wir überhaupt zu agieren
können wie wir das immer noch eher einen
gegeneinander als ein miteinander und
die werden ja wie ich das noch sagen
dafür werden ja in zukunft nehmen wir
mal an dass wir haben das virus ein
dermaßen ich bin jetzt nicht sagen im
griff aber es ist ein bisschen
zurückgedrängt klimawandel steht immer
noch vor der tür da dies die passt genau
da rein hier von youtube ein etwas
schwierig auszusprechen username du
erinnert vielleicht frage ist folge des
klimawandels die sind schlimmer als die
das als von corona auf lange sicht
gesehen warum behandelten wir corona als
krise den klimawandel aber nicht das ist
ja auch etwas was die klimaaktivisten
von prayers for future klettert auch
schon angemeldet haben guck mal was
möglich wäre wenn wir alle wollten woran
liegt das dass wir dieses akute thema
behandeln und das langfristige
ignorieren
genau aus dem grund akut und langfristig
das sind für uns zwei völlig
unterschiedliche unterschiedliche
risiken ein wenn etwas akutes wird auch
unmittelbar was unternommen
das virus ist unsichtbar ist aber in uns
direkt spürbar wird vielleicht in einem
bekannten oder freundeskreis auch schon
zu einer schweren erkrankung geführt
haben das heißt wir haben bilder
wir haben emotionen dafür und wir können
wir haben mindestens eine form der
anschauung dafür klimawandel ist
statistik klima ist das über 30 jahre
gemittelte wetter und wir sehen diese
allmählichen veränderungen und sehen nun
dass eben die natur aufgrund der
globalen erwärmung immer stärker und
schneller und schneller schneller
reagiert extrem wird der ereignisse wie
zb überflutungen von dörfern die führen
natürlich auch sofort zu einer reaktion
dann haben wir normalerweise die
diskussionen dann ist diese überflutung
also ein starkregen ereignis zum
beispiel hängt es mit dem klimawandel
zusammen oder ist es nur wetter
inzwischen haben eine zuordnung
gesellschaft die uns ganz klar sagt mit
der hilfe also mithilfe der statistische
methoden das mit globaler erwärmung
diese extremwetter ereignisse immer
häufiger werden das ist eine erkenntnis
der letzten jahre und macht allmählich
immer deutlicher dass der klimawandel
immer akuter und akuter wird aber ist
noch nicht akut genug um tatsächlich
unmittelbare schnelle handlungen der von
regierungsseite und auch von
ökonomischer seite zu initiieren
möglicherweise wird diese corona krise
uns und da bin ich völlig bei frau
thunberg uns schon klar machen
zu was wir in der lage sind wenn wir
wollen das ist erstmal das potenzial des
optional das was uns an möglichkeit zur
verfügung steht das wird hier gezeigt
und das kann auf der einen seite er uns
ja sehr positiv stimmen weil vielleicht
gelingt es uns ja tatsächlich auch bei
den klimawandel solche starken aktionen
zu erzeugen
auf der anderen seite müssen wir aber
befürchten dass natürlich der
ökonomische bereich durch diese massive
krise in den tagen nach dem virus fragen
wird hört man jetzt mit einem klima mit
dem klima einschränkungen
einschränkungen bei zum beispiel bei den
grenzwerten für emissionen von
kohlendioxid und so weiter könnte da
nicht ein bisschen großzügiger sein wir
haben jetzt diese schwere krise hinter
uns und so weiter da müssen wir
aufpassen dass hier der schwung nicht
verloren geht und dass eben die
klimaziele nicht aus dem aus dem auge
dass wir dem klimaziele aus dem auge
verlieren
was ich interessant finde ist wir werden
natürlich am ende dieses jahres werden
wir sehen was es ausmacht wenn unsere
wirtschaft deutlich schwächer geworden
ist dann haben wir natürlich auch viel
geringere emissionen und ein lied namens
zentimeter kann kann uns sogar zeigen
wie wieder wie die wie der himmel über
europa aussieht vorher und nachher genau
das wollen auch hier user tatsächlich
wissen ob man das irgendwie schon
voraussagen kann zum beispiel hier
chesney auf youtube möchte wissen wird
die umwelt durch die maßnahmen im kampf
gegen das corona virus wirklich stark
entlastet und wird dieser effekt falls
vorhanden lange vorhalten
eine andere richtung fragt anna lena
büchner ob die umwelt profitiert oder
könnte sich während des ausnahmezustands
möglicherweise etwas erholen
oder sind das jetzt alles nur so
kurzfristige effekt und wenn wir alles
ja wieder hochfahren das hat es wieder
verpufft also es ist sicherlich so dass
es so lokale effekte gibt es gab ja
schon bilder von venedig zum beispiel
die kanäle sind salz wasser ist sauber
es herrscht dort flora und fauna wie
schon seit ewigkeiten nicht mehr
das sieht man an vielen ecken das nicht
sich die natur da relativ schnell auch
wieder erholen kann aber das ist kein
globales phänomen
und das ist schon gar nicht nachhaltig
denn wir müssen natürlich befürchten
dass wenn diese globale maschinerie
wieder in voller gänze anläuft dann
werden die emission natürlich wieder
hoch gehen und dann werden natürlich
auch die entsprechenden effekte
weitergehen insgesamt ist es so dass die
natur in den letzten jahrzehnten bereits
so stark auf die globale erwärmung
reagiert hat dass jetzt nicht die paar
monate da ausreichend um zum beispiel
des permafrost auftauen in sibirien zu
stoppen dass das archiv
es schmilzt und das antarktische eis
schmilzt usw das wird sich alles nicht
verändern wir werden sehen
diese diese diesen eindruck den werden
wir sicherlich in den diagrammen merken
wir werden sehen wie die co2 emissionen
absinken werden sehen wie die stickoxide
absingen usw
das kann jetzt ein satellit namens
sentinel zb für europa schon zeigen dann
gibt es fotos vorher nachher wie war es
vor der krise wie ist es jetzt so weiter
sieht man deutlich werden die geringere
feinstaubbelastung in den ballungsräumen
wir haben da geringere
stickoxidbelastung usw usw
wie die zahlenwerte für kohlendioxid
oder methan aussehen weiß ich momentan
nicht
heute gibt's natürlich eine reihe von
natürlichen quellen die wir angeregt
haben durch die globale erwärmung und
das wird man auch momentan nicht stoppen
können
insgesamt wäre es gut wenn natürlich da
ja eben tatsächlich das wachstum das
wirtschaftliche wachstum direkt mit der
emission von treibhausgasen verbunden
ist ihr kleiner das wachstum ist umso
kleiner sind auch die
treibhausgasemissionen und umso besser
für das klima allerdings kann man das
natürlich so ohne weiteres gar nicht in
die tat umsetzen
denn was würde das bedeuten für die
ärmeren länder auf der welt das wäre
eine katastrophe man sieht hier wir
kommen aus diesen aus dem problem
kreisen die wir vor dem corona virus
hatten nicht raus wir werden weiter
daran arbeiten müssen und für die
industrialisierten länder bedeutet es
vor allen dingen so schnell wie möglich
in die erneuerbaren energien und zwar
mit allem was uns zur verfügung steht
wir gucken uns gleich mal an was es für
szenarien nach oben und gibt einmal
möchte ich ganz kurz zusammenfassen dass
der chat herausgibt das spannende ist
nämlich dass sich unsere kommentatoren
gerade in zwei lager spalten einmal in
die das ganze quasi verleugnen oder
abtun oder auch sagen das stimmt alles
nicht und menschen die ihnen zu stimmen
hätte christian potthoff zum beispiel
meine das ist eine ordnung stellte die
natur da gerade gibt aber das ist ja
doch wieder mal ein thema was die
bevölkerung zumindest teilweise sehr
stark spaltet was meinen sie woran liegt
das dass da auch so emotional reagiert
wird das einfach nicht auf kühne fakten
geguckt wird so haben sie schon sondern
dass es da gleich wieder mit mit mit
wilden worten aufeinander losgegangen
wird das weiß ich auch nicht also ich
verstehe dass ich habe in den letzten
wochen auch teilweise e mails bekommen
wo ich also gedacht
kann doch nicht wahr sein die personalie
wir reden doch hier nicht über
irgendwelche persönlichen meinungen
visionen hoffnung oder träume also alle
wissenschaften die damit befasst sind
wir dem problem und wir benutzen ja
letztlich wenn wir über viren sprechen
oder moleküle sprechen benutzen wir ja
das gesamte wissen der
naturwissenschaften
das heißt von physik chemie biologie der
medizin und vor allen dingen in diesem
sinn auch der medien also der der ganz
wissenschaftlichen medizin muss gar
nicht unbedingt um den patienten geht
sondern vor allen dingen erst einmal
darum die ursache wirkungs zusammenhänge
in ihrer reinen form zu erkennen um dann
zu merken okay was bedeutet dass in dem
system mensch also wenn es dann
tatsächlich die patienten geht wenn wir
in die mikrobiologie gehen usw
das sind ja alles gebiete die nennt man
empirische forschung und empirische
forschung also erforschung mit
erfahrungen
das heißt erfahrung wird hier gemacht
durch experimente und beobachtung die
haben vor allen dingen ein problem für
viele ich glaube dass das ein echtes
problem ist das ist das quantitativ das
heißt es wird gerechnet und es wird
gemessen und rechnungen und messung und
sind nun völlig bar jeder meinung also
1&1 ist 2 und nicht 1,9 wie die einen
meinen oder 2,1 wie die anderen meint
sondern zwei das heißt wir haben es mit
evidenzbasierter wissenschaft zu tun
da geht es um fakten und tatsachen und
da geht es nicht darum kann doch jeder
sagen was er will
es geht um natur gesetzlichkeiten die
unter bestimmten rand und
anfangsbedingungen eben anderes andere
lösungen bringen als unter anderen
bedingungen ja und das bedeutet wir
haben es hier nicht mit einem
diskussionsraum zu tun wo jeder sagen
kann was er will sondern das ist auch
kein radikaler konstruktivismus nach dem
motto diese ganze physik die da machen
das doch alles nur einbildung unseres
ions sondern es ist tatsächlich da
draußen so diese viren haben keine
kommunikationszentren wir können nicht
mit ihnen sprechen auch immer den
eindruck hat zum beispiel stichwort
china
die entscheidend jetzt von einem tag von
anderen ihre ihre infektion sind auf
null
da habe ich schon mal so gesagt offenbar
hat die central der kommunistischen
partei in china einen guten draht zu den
virus um ihnen zu sagen jetzt wird nicht
mehr infizieren
das ist natürlich quatsch das kann ja
gar nicht sein ja und genau so ist es
bei klimawandel genauso wir können mit
der natur nicht sprechen wir können nur
mathematische fragen an sie stellen und
hurra die matte die natur gibt
mathematische antworten im sinne von
statistischen äußerung usw
also statistischen statistischen
messdaten und das hat für viele menschen
den charakter das kann doch nicht wahr
sein ich kann doch sonst auch immer
meine meinung sagen ja bitte können sie
aber wer behauptet die erde sei eine
scheibe oder die sonne wird im westen
auf gehen und nicht im osten und ähnlich
andere dinge
da kann ich nur einfach sagen ja du
kannst natürlich von deiner meinung
bringt kann ich dich nicht abbringen ich
kann dir nur sagen sie ist falsch
und so ist es jetzt hier bei vielen
verschwörungstheorien zudem corona virus
leider auch die aussage dass wir ja
alles so hysterisch man soll das nicht
übertreiben usw
nein ich würde es ganz anders sehen ganz
egal was diese kritikerinnen und
kritiker sagen das ist eine ganz große
sache die wir momentan folgen
vollbringen nämlich aus rücksicht auf
viele die schwer erkrankt sind unser
gesundheitssystem zu schützen das kann
keine hysterie sein dass es humanismus
pur und darauf bin ich ehrlich gesagt
ziemlich stolz dass wir das so
hinkriegen hierzu mal wissen in die
zukunft ist ein bisschen schwierig grad
noch weil das ist ja immer ist ja immer
so dass wir enke man kann wenn wir bei
daten bleiben das ist ja ihr
lieblingsfach man kann sie extrapolieren
und dann kann man verschiedene
modellrechnungen machen und dann mal
gucken wo es hingehen würde wenn man da
und dort an der schraube dreht das haben
wissenschaftler schon gemacht und
carolin wie man hat mal vier szenarien
für uns zusammengefasst
so etwas haben die meisten von uns noch
nicht erlebt dass corona virus hat uns
voll unter kontrolle
ausgangs beschränkungen das verbot von
treffen mit mehr als zwei leuten sie
nicht zusammenleben die überlegung über
handy daten zu überwachen wer mit wem
kontakt hat
vieles was eben noch science fiction war
könnte schnell zur gewohnheit werden
gleichzeitig bekommt die digitalisierung
einen neuen schub
wer kann macht home office die
downloadzahlen von apps für
videokonferenzen und schul übungen stein
telemedizin mit virtuellen sprechstunden
und behandlungen könnte der durchbruch
gelingen stream jetzt noch mehr serien
und filme gehen wir irgendwann überhaupt
noch ins kino
selbst die soziale isolation ist nur
eine räumliche dank sozialer medien und
video calls aber ob die auch auf lange
sicht direkte kontakte ersetzen und
sozialer werden wir durch die isolation
jedenfalls nicht
der gemeinsinn steigt an vielen orten
entstehen nachbarschaftshilfen viele von
uns spenden oder versuchen besonders
jetzt regional zu kaufen und lokale
geschäfte zu unterstützen die unsere
zukunft nach chur wird 19 tatsächlich
aussehen könnte hat das
deutsch-österreichische zukunftsinstitut
in vier szenarien beschrieben wie wird
es kommen
szenario 1 komplette isolation der
shutdown wird normalität der schutz vor
infektionen bleibt oberste priorität und
jeder ist sich in zukunft selbst der
nächste
szenario 2 der systemcrash die welt
kommt nicht mehr aus dem krisenmodus
heraus die wirtschaft auch nicht
szenario 3 ist der rückzug ins private
wir stellen in zukunft die familie und
das unmittelbare umfeld über alles
globalisierung ade
oder trifft szenario 4 1
wir passen uns an und gehen gestärkt aus
der krise raus statt profit gier rückt
ein miteinander in den fokus das allen
nützt
welchen weg wir genau einschlagen liegt
an uns allen
ja dieses große thema besprechen wir
heute mit harald lesch zdf
wissenschaftsjournalist und der
ex-moderator ganz kurz zusammenfassend
was ihr bisher es besprochen haben wir
haben geredet über wissenschaft und was
wissenschaft kam und was sie nicht kann
wo die grenzen sind und dass wir gerade
uns einfach in einem erst ziemlich
schwierigen fahrwasser befinden weil
ganz einfach noch unbekannt ist wenn es
heißt wir müssen uns mit mit einer
gewissen unsicherheit müssen uns daran
gewöhnen wir haben darüber geredet was
das ganze für mensch und natur bedeutet
nämlich dass und jedoch das deutliche
konsequenzen sehen die sich vielleicht
ändern müssen und jetzt ist die frage
was könnte sich dann vielleicht ändern
sie haben jetzt gerade die verschiedenen
szenarien gesehen hat der schwäche ist
halten sie denn für am realistischsten
bis jetzt sagen sie nicht das was sie
sich wünschen sondern was sie
wahrscheinlich für wahrscheinlichsten
halten also zunächst einmal werden wir
natürlich so eine schrittweise lockerung
der maßnahmen sehen das heißt wir werden
schrittweise wieder sozusagen das
gesamtsystem anschalten in den mit den
verschiedenen parametern und die schulen
werden wieder geöffnet werden
wahrscheinlich zunächst einmal für die
höheren klassen dann werden verschiedene
betriebe wieder angeworfen werden
die landwirtschaft muss natürlich
irgendwann wieder angeworfen werden
und so wird man allmählich sehen wie
unser land wieder in eine bestimmte
betriebstemperatur bekommt die frage ist
was dann passiert nämlich kaum haben wir
unser land in auf betriebstemperatur
gebracht droht uns schon der winter und
im winter kann die nächste virus welle
kommen
das heißt die nächste epidemie die
nächste pandemie kann uns dann
möglicherweise wieder zurück treiben
das hängt ein bisschen davon ab wie gut
auch jetzt unser unsere daten lage sein
wird wie gut wir kennen lernen wie viele
von uns die virus infektion schon hinter
sich gebracht haben ohne große symptome
denn all diese menschen die diese
infektion hinter sich haben die können
ja dann wieder in den normalbetrieb
gehen die können wieder arbeiten
und insofern denke ich es wird so eine
mischung werden aus 419 4 wird
sicherlich eine wichtige rolle spielen
dass wir uns nämlich anpassen
ich weiß nicht ob das dann so wie soll
ich sagen so sozial romantisch wird und
wir nicht mehr nach dem geld streben usw
aber wir haben natürlich eine inzwischen
das sozialstruktur in deutschland auch
eine struktur der beziehungen und der
der beziehung der einzelnen aber auch
der gruppen untereinander
die lässt eine ein rückzug ins private
gar nicht mehr zu
denn das würde bedeuten dass sehr viele
personen praktisch alleine wäre denn
viele von ihnen haben keine familie
dh das halte ich zum beispiel für ein
szenario das was kaum tragfähig sein
wird insgesamt schon nicht es wird
sicherlich ideen geben zum beispiel in
deutschland wie viel von der pharma
pharmazeutischen produktion brauchen wir
hier zu hause um im ernstfall in der
lage zu sein
wichtige medikamente selber herzustellen
hier zu hause heißt europa nicht
deutschland sondern europa ich hoffe
sehr dass die europäer unter dieser
krise enger zusammenwachsen auch bei
allen problemen vor denen wir momentan
stehen also gerade in den ländern die
notstandsgesetze erlassen haben um er
aus politischen gründen denn aus
medizinischen gründen zu agieren
aber ich denke dass europa
zusammenwachsen kann und dass man eben
auch feststellen wird gesundheit wird
uns so wichtig werden in zukunft dass
wir es nicht mehr privaten shareholdern
überlassen werden geld damit zu
verdienen sondern dass wir vielleicht
die gesamt das gesamte gesundheitssystem
rekommunalisieren also auf deutsch
gesagt wieder in die in staatliche hände
begeben das wird sicherlich passieren
wir werden einen rebound kriegen
gegenüber diesen neoliberalen
privatisierungswahn der letzten 20 25 30
jahren das wird sicherlich passen so
dass krankenhäuser kritisiert wurden und
das gesundheitswesen machen sie also es
geht es wird wir werden intensiver über
den begriff der daseinsvorsorge
nachdenken was ist für uns so wichtig
das müssen wir in unseren händen haben
und ich bin sicher dass wir auch darüber
nachdenken werden die machen wir das mit
der digitalen kommunikation
das sollten wir vielleicht viel viel
mehr drauf achten dass das eben viel
sicherer wird denn wir sehen das in
solchen stress und krisensituationen ist
die digitale kommunikation die einzige
möglichkeit ich würde übrigens ungern
von social distance singen sprechen
ich halte das eher für einen physiker
distance -ing das heißt wir sind uns
darum glaube ich auch schon anja aber
ich glaube dass wir sozial tatsächlich
momentan viel enger beieinander sind als
das vorher der fall ist weil man einfach
merkt mensch meier da ist ja noch der
oder ist ja noch die und da muss ich
doch mal hören wie ist das so und das
hat schon das hat schon etwas
verbindendes und ich glaube dass für
viele menschen dass sich daraus auch
gedanken entwickeln die für ihre eigene
zukunft für die zukunft ihrer peergroup
von großer bedeutung sind und das ganze
wird sich zu einer bewegung in
deutschland ein ganz europa
hoffentlich zusammentun wo wir uns
darüber wo wir darüber nachdenken wir
sind hier wir sind wieder da sind sie da
sind sie aber doch sehr positiv oder
oder optimistisch wenn ich mal gucken
was so die asiatischen länder aus der
ersten satzbälle gelernt haben war das
vor allem für müssen pandemiepläne
entwickeln
wir müssen gucken wie wir das schnell im
griff kriegen aber von einem ich sag mal
diesen ganzen bewegungen die die sie wie
sie jetzt sprechen oder hoffen habe ich
da nicht viel gehört die machen einfach
weiter wie bisher und das ist auch so
ein bisschen das szenario was mir fehlt
dieses szenario fünf wir überstehen das
ganze und dann läuft einfach alles
weiter wie bisher weiter wie bisher und
die klimakrise auf die steuern wir auch
weiterhin zu wird nicht passieren ich
glaube nicht dass wir das irgendjemand
also zumindest ich rede jetzt mal über
die europäische kultur
soweit ich das kenne ich glaube dass wir
alle ziemlich geschockt sind das ist
eine traumatische erfahrung war und ist
nach wie vor sind wir sind ja noch
mitten drin und dass wir aus diesem
trauma heraus eine ganze reihe von
drummer heraus eine ganze reihe von
konsequenzen ziehen werden und zwar
zunächst einmal möglicherweise nur in so
eine art von gesellschaftlicher
untergrund strömung dass wir werden wir
werden nicht so weiter machen wir werden
sehen dass vielen vielen menschen
gesundheit auf einmal eine wichtige
rolle spielt und damit natürlich auch
die umwelt eine wichtige rolle weil die
umwelt hat was mit unserer gesundheit zu
tun
wir werden sehen dass viele betriebe
inzwischen die jetzt zum beispiel durch
die krise durch müssen sich enger
zusammen stellen werden die werden da
wird es nicht mehr darum gehen beliebig
weit zb die tentakel die ökonomischen
tentakel um die welt aus zulegen da wird
man sich tatsächlich ein bisschen
konzentrieren deswegen sage ich den
rückgang der globalisierung wird auf
jeden fall stattfinden
ich glaube nicht dass man einfach so
weitermachen kann wie bisher das wird
nicht mehr so funktionieren ob man das
arrangieren diese frage sondern auch
weil der ob die tatsächlich das
verstehen was was wir folgen
unser handeln hat und ob man tatsächlich
diesen ich sag mal diesen gedankensprung
hinkriegt von unsere krankenhäuser
laufen fordert das hat was damit zu tun
dass wir unserer umwelt teilweise
wirklich zu großen schaden zugefügt
haben das ist ja schon recht relativ
große transferleistungen das ist eine
große transferleistung aber man darf
nicht vergessen wir haben zeit das was
wir momentan erleben ist ja ich glaube
christian drosten hat es gesagt ist eine
katastrophe in zeitlupe
wir haben es ja nicht mit einer
einer momentanen auto also ganz
schnellen geschichte zu tun also eine
überflutung die nach 34 tagen wieder aus
dem mädchen verschwindet sondern seit
über vier wochen gibt es nur noch ein
thema in allen medialen kanälen und das
heißt dass corona virus und die
krankheit corvette 19
das heißt wir haben es jetzt zum ersten
mal mit etwas zu tun wo die bevölkerung
gar nicht mehr auskommt egal wohin man
sich auch dreht und wendet immer taucht
irgendwo dieses virus und seine
konsequenzen auf viele von den
naturkatastrophen von den dingen wo man
gesagt hat also das muss aber jetzt was
ändern das war ja was ganz anderes jetzt
handelt es sich um zumindest zeitlich
begrenzt um eine sehr chronische sehr
deutliche sehr intensive bedrohung
unseres gesamten lebensstils aber wie
das team um kathleen am boden hängen
bleiben wir sind gut darin sich an das
zu verdrängen und dann wieder zu
verlassen
die unangenehmen das war also ich frage
mich manchmal ob wir nicht einen richtig
großen systemcrash brauchen wo es
wirklich zusammen bricht um dann
deutlich daraus zu lernen dürfen uns
anders man muss also möchte ich also
dass sie nicht wünschen aber tatsächlich
ist ja die erfahrung wichtig anders wird
erst dann wirst komplett
zusammengebrochen ist also dass ich
meine wir sind schon nah dran an
komplett also wenn man sich mal anschaut
was die jetzt momentan alles passiert
wir können ja ziemlich dankbar sein dass
das system deutschland zu betreiben sehr
gut funktioniert wir haben gas wir haben
wasser das wasser ist wahr wir haben
elektrischen strom und all diese ganzen
dinge diese versorgungsleistung werden
ja grandios erbracht wenn das auch noch
wegfallen würde
ich denke man das szenario blackout von
marcus berg was dann da passieren würde
wenn also dann auf einmal der die
piraterie und und andere dinge auf der
straße stattfinden würden
es ist ja bemerkenswert dass die
amerikaner wären die deutschen klopapier
und die franzosen rotwein kaufen oder
kommt und kondomen kaufen die amerikaner
waffen und das gehört sogar zu ihren
grundrechten und es hat dazu geführt
dass neben tankstellen supermärkten und
drogerien in amerika vor allem die
waffen läden geöffnet sind weil die
lobby ist irgendwie geschafft hat das zu
verhindern dass die geschlossen werden
es der wahnsinn
also diese zustände haben wir in europa
nicht ich glaube dass gerade die
europäer mit den sozialsystemen die sie
haben und mit all den möglichkeiten ihre
gesellschaften zu stabilisieren hier
eine ganz wichtige rolle spielen können
um sozusagen also wirklich vorbildlich
ein neue schritte zu gehen vor allen
dingen hin in lösungswege die wir
sowieso betreten müssen
nämlich klimaschutz energiewende und so
weiter das wird nämlich die rolle
spielen ökologische landwirtschaft alles
das was wir jetzt an krisen in unserer
in dieser medialen palette die wir über
überall in europa anbieten den menschen
tatsächlich präsentieren all diese all
diese probleme verschwinden nicht
sondern werden jetzt vielleicht fehlen
erst einmal deutlich und ich hoffe sehr
dass aus dieser nischen bewegung wo ja
doch relativ weniger am anfang nur dabei
waren jetzt viele in den sozio wie hast
du so schön so zur ökonomischen
mainstream kommen und optionen anbieten
zumindest optionen anbieten dass wir was
anderes machen können wenn wir uns dann
für die alte lösung entscheiden also für
das business as usual
lasst uns lieber so weitermachen wie
bisher dann sind wir selber schuld ich
denke wir haben die möglichkeit
alternativen zu bedenken wir kriegen wir
wie wir denken sie momentan auch die
frage ist ob wir sehen ob wir ins
handeln kommen und damit eben auch die
richtigen entscheidungen für die zukunft
treffen denn das interessante ist ja
frei dies for future
da war der ruf denkt doch an uns junge
jetzt aktuell in der krise denken wir
vor allen dingen an die alten also das
ist doch interessant sein können wie wir
jetzt genauer ganz genau genau aber es
ist natürlich es ist natürlich schon ein
interessantes wechsel spielt dass diese
gesellschaften auf einmal beginnen sich
ihrer verschiedenen gruppen wirklich
klar zu werden und zu wissen wie wichtig
ist das ist das zusammen und ich glaube
am ende ich hoffe sehr dass am ende
dieses jahres stehen wird puma erstens
wir leben noch wir haben's gut
überstanden und wir machen was anderes
daraus also aus dieser katastrophe kann
eben tatsächlich auch was richtig gutes
werden die frage ist ob wir die chancen
wahrnehmen oder nicht sie haben völlig
recht der mensch ist möglicherweise wie
kant es sagt immanuel kant das mal
gesagt hat aus einem großen holz
geschnitzt aber wir können mit hilfe
unserer institution mit hilfe unseres
freiheitlichen unsere meinungsfreiheit
und der diskussionsfreudigkeit der
transparenz von entscheidungen mit dazu
beitragen dass die menschen vertrauen
haben in die staatlichen institutionen
auch in die wissenschaftlichen
institutionen und dann bin ich
eigentlich guter dinge aber vielleicht
liegt es auch daran dass sich protestant
bin tatsächlich noch ein apfelbäumchen
pflanzen letzten sehen wir tatsächlich
auch in den umfragen in die wir gestern
im zdf politbarometer publiziert haben
dass das vertrauen doch relativ starkes
das teilweise menschen sich ja sogar
noch
strengere maßnahmen wünschen nicht
glaube es waren um die wir 23 prozent
die das gefordert haben ich werfe einen
blick in die kommentare
hier gibt es ganz verschiedene
kommentare zu den verschiedenen
themenblöcken die wir jetzt bearbeitet
haben
einmal schreibt ghz fäden rückgang der
globalisierung das wäre super also er
ist da ganz bei ihnen
michael degen meint stärkung der region
ist das wichtigere und tattoo fordert
unheimlich unabhängig von china werden
das ist tatsächlich auch ein effekt den
wir jetzt gesehen haben wenn wir alle
auf ein land gehen und das hat probleme
und muss alles anhalten dann hält der
rest der welt quasi auch an
ansonsten gibt es fragen hier noch wenn
wir in die zukunft gucken
zur digitalisierung von rika trailer auf
youtube wie schätzen sie den einfluss
der korona krise auf die zukunft der
digitalisierung ein und vor allem auf
die digitalisierung in der bildung und
lehre ich meine ich sehe mit erstaunen
dass auf einmal zum beispiel meine frau
konferenzen machen kann mit dem ganzen
kollegium zu 30 über große anbieter das
funktioniert auf einmal home office
funktioniert da wo man uns früher nicht
gedacht hätte dass das funktionieren
würde
aber die frage ist bleibt das ist das
heißt der sprung nach vorne
ich glaube dass wir auf jeden fall jetzt
die option kennen neben dem normalen
also neben normalen miteinander also in
3d dass wir jetzt die option
kennenlernen das geht auch in 2d
es ist nicht so gut wie in 3d aber es
geht und dass man sich auf diese weise
tatsächlich in so einer brücken zeit
tatsächlich behelfen kann das ist ja für
viele weitere zukünftige lebenssituation
ist das ja ganz wichtig denn wie gesagt
wir werden eine weitere welle im herbst
bekommen das können wir gar nicht
ausschließen
gutes wird ja dann je nachdem wie
schnell und impfstoff da ist wird es
noch die eine oder andere welle geben
und es wird vielleicht auch noch andere
bedrohungen geben wo wir immer wieder
darauf zurückkommen kennen können und
wir haben es kennen gelernt und wir
lernen es funktioniert und selbst die
die altvorderen die sagen das will ich
überhaupt nicht wie gehabt nichts mehr
zu tun haben stellen festhält so
schlecht ist das gar nicht und
tatsächlich ist heute vieles möglich
woran man früher wovon man früher ja nur
träumen konnte auf der anderen seite
werden wir aber durch diese krise auch
feststellen wie wichtig der direkte
kontakt
wie wichtig das beisammensein ist und
zwar nicht das beisammensein nur einfach
face to face sondern dass man einfach
miteinander zusammen ist und dass man
sich auch in anführungsstriche bisschen
näher rücken kann und auch noch mal ein
anderes vertrauensverhältnis entwickelt
als das im digitalen bereich der fall
ist wo man nie genau sicher sein kann ob
nicht doch irgendjemand dann nicht
dazwischen gehackt hat und das ganze
programm dann oder die ganzen daten die
da bereitgestellt werden dann
irgendjemand zugänglich gemacht werden
das ist ja immer die große und große
unsicherheitsfaktor und in einem
normalen gespräch mit menschen die man
kennt denen man vertraut da sieht es ja
ganz anders sie hat sich hier zu sehen
ob sie mir jetzt lieber dem studio als
auf uns und bildschirm aber manchmal
nicht mehr so viel sollte man so ein
paar kommentare hier einbinden also
einmal gibt es die diskussion um
meinungsfreiheit vielleicht können wir
mal kurz auf meinem bildschirm hier
schalten da meldet sich zu wort
meinungsfreiheit die worte leider schon
vor jahren durch das netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz und co abgeschafft
ist zweifelt doch gerade deshalb so
viele leute am klimawandel und ich mache
mal klammer auf und von corona weil eine
offene diskussion nicht stattfindet ich
würde gerne allein durch das vorlesen
dieses kommentares dir liebe beweisen
dass ist eine offene diskussion gibt
dass wir fast alle kommentare dulden
solange sich nicht die meinungsfreiheit
irgendwie einschränken oder beleidigend
werden und wir haben es aber auch gerade
gesagt hat hat lösch deutlich drauf
gewesen man muss halt auch bei den
fakten bleiben und zum beispiel dass das
netzwerk durchsetzungs gesetz die
meinungsfreiheit abgeschafft hätte ist
leider überhaupt nicht der fall was
heißt leider ist falsch alles nicht der
fall zum glück nicht dafür ist es leider
überhaupt nicht so wirkungsvoll wollte
ich sagen wie es sein sollte spricht
gegen hass kommentare & co hat das
relativ wenig bewirkt so dann aber hier
eine frage die finde ich noch ganz
spannend die dreht sich nicht um die
zukunft um den dreht sich um zahlen also
ihr lieblings gebiet verlässt sich mal
gucken wo ich sie finde sie haben ja
schon etwas dazu gesagt in einem ihrer
videos bei ging es das finde ich diesen
kommentar nicht mehr es wird zu viel
geschrieben es ging um die frage der
zahlen die fehlen sterben menschen durch
corona oder mit corona was ist die
parallele zur grippe warum gab dass die
frage kommt immer wieder vor 2 3
dann nicht genauso große maßnahmen als
wir eine große krippe seller hatten
vielleicht fangen wir mal an noch einmal
zu den zahlen wo wir ganz am anfang
waren welche zahlen haben wir eigentlich
welche sind belastbar und wie kann man
jetzt überhaupt sagen ob die menschen
durch corona oder mit corinna sterben
also ob sie nicht sowieso in zwei wochen
verstorben werden weil sie halt schwer
krebskrank waren wir haben natürlich wir
haben natürlich keine welt wo wir das
testen können eine welt ohne krone haben
wir uns derzeit nicht wir haben nur die
eine insofern ist diese sind diese
fragen immer müßig man muss in der tat
nachdem diese pandemie abgeflaut ist
muss man sich diese diese fragen stellt
und dann auch in zukunft in die
entsprechenden antworten adäquat
anzupassen
aktuell gehen wir von den zahlen aus wie
sie zum beispiel dass john hopkins des
johns hopkins universität in amerika
präsentiert aber auch das robert koch
institut das heißt wir haben eine
gewisse menge an infizierten in
deutschland
die sterberate ist entsprechend und
natürlich glaube ich wird bei den
patienten von denen ausgegangen wird
dass sie an cupid 19 gestorben sind
das heißt sie sind an den wirkungen des
corona virus verstorben das heißt das
virus hat in den körper des patienten
diese lungenkranke krankheit ausgelöst
und darin ist der patient verstorben
dass es noch andere gründe für das
sterben geben könnte ist unbestritten
steckt man nicht drin aber auf der aber
es wird mir würde man würde natürlich
jetzt am besten würde man praktisch
jeden verstorbenen obduzieren würde sich
genau anschauen was wir was war die
ursache
da gibt es ja auch jetzt theorien warum
das nicht gemacht wird auch die werden
von menschen auf youtube in die welt
gesetzt und wann wird gesagt stimmt das
überhaupt warum wird nicht obduziert
ja ja ja aber das ist natürlich ist das
geht natürlich grundsätzlich dass man
also zweifel dass es zweiflerin und
zweifler von irgendwas gibt ist ja klar
ich gehe von der kompetenz derjenigen
ärztinnen und ärzte vor vor ort jeweils
aus und die unterschreiben den
totenschein die sind dabei gewesen das
pflegepersonal ist dabei gewesen die
wissen warum ein mann oder eine frau in
einem krankenhaus verstorben ist das
heißt sie wissen das sehr genau und da
gibt es glaube ich auch gar keinen grund
jetzt die diesen quellen zu misstrauen
zumal ja dann auch gleich immer wieder
so eine nationale oder transnational das
finde ich ja höchst interessant
verschwörung vermutet wird dass sie also
insgesamt jetzt auf einmal werden die
die sterbezahlen nach oben geschoben
es ist in der tat richtig das risiko für
sehr viel sehr viel ältere menschen ist
deutlich höher
an diesen coup mit 19 zu versterben als
die jüngeren das bedeutet das deutet
darauf hin dass wenn das virus in den
körper eines älteren menschen eindringt
ist offenbar zu viel zu heftigen schäden
kommen kann die dann relativ schnell
auch zum tode führen aber trotzdem kann
man jetzt nicht also die diese ursache
wirkungs zusammenhänge
hier sind so dass das virus eine
bestimmte ein bestimmtes krankheitsbild
auslöst das dann im zusammenhang mit dem
gesamtsystem mensch eben zudem ganz zu
der ganz schweren erkrankung führt die
dann insgesamt zum tode führen kann oder
zum tode geführt hat das lässt sich
glaube ich nicht so ohne weiteres von
einander trennen aber der ausgangspunkt
war die die virusinfektion
das ist er der trigger sozusagen hier
träger der die ganze sache zum punkt
bringt man muss ein bisschen glaube ich
hier aufpassen menschen sind komplexe
systeme komplexe systeme zeichnen sich
dadurch aus dass winzige veränderungen
der anfangsbedingungen zu katastrophalen
veränderungen bei den wirkungen führen
wir sind also nicht so determiniert dass
wir praktisch dass das immer ganz genau
gleich läuft sondern wenn eine bestimmte
wenn eine bestimmte störung stattfindet
die die zu diesen großen wirkungen führt
dann ist ein system was weniger
resilient ist also weniger
widerstandsfähig viel schneller dabei
eben zu brechen also ein übergang an
katastrophalen übergang vom leben zum
tod zu vollführen als ein system was wie
widerstandsfähiger ist und damit eben
auf äußeren stress also auf eine äußere
störung einfach flexibler reagieren kann
das lässt sich nicht voneinander trennen
aber ich muss sagen die zahlen die das
robert-koch-institut oder die johns
hopkins universität liefern
die haben ja immer so ein bisschen sohn
versucht das robert koch institut kommt
ein bisschen später das sind die zahlen
mit denen wir arbeiten müssen das sind
die zahlen die uns klar und deutlich
sagen welche katastrophen in italien in
spanien vor allen dingen auch in den usa
aber auch in teilen von frankreich sich
abgespielt haben
das ist ziemlich dramatisch und es ist
jeweils die vor allen dingen die ältere
bevölkerung davon betroffen aber es
trifft auch jüngere und das trifft auch
solche die eigentlich gar keine
zumindestens sichtbaren vorerkrankungen
gehabt haben oder vorerkrankungen gehabt
haben die irgendwie bekannt gewesen
wären so ist es sind sehr sehr massive
krankheit auf ein paar kommentare
eingehende wird behauptet einer merkel
hätte
na und wäre infiziert das stimmt nicht
drei tests waren negativ
dann wird hier gesagt schweden macht es
besser als deutschland
von franz peters auf youtube auch da
müssen wir sagen schweden ist dabei
gerade den gleichen weg zu gehen wie
alle anderen europäischen ländern weil
sie merken dass ihre doch sehr wachsen
maßnahmen vielleicht doch nicht die
beste idee gewesen sind und wir sind
jetzt wieder am anfang mit einem
kommentar den ich abschließend noch mal
von kathleen over auf facebook vorlesen
möchte
wir brauchen genaue informationen ich
glaube das können wir beide
unterschreiben herrscht das problem ist
einfach dass wir sind in einer sich
entwickelnden lage und da muss man
einfach ein bisschen geduld haben das
haben sie mal von jahren schlimmer sagt
so ist es einfach ruhig bleiben und es
gibt einen wunderbaren satz ich glaube
jetzt von niklas luhmann vertrauen
reduziert komplexität wenn wir vertrauen
haben dann macht es unser leben
einfacher und ich habe wirklich den
eindruck wir können diesen institutionen
die uns informieren die auch die
entscheidungen treffen
vertrauen und ich glaube das ist das
allerwichtigste wirklich tatsächlich
geduldig bleiben ruhig bleiben sie ruhig
halten und unter uns gesagt maske
aufziehen und letzten endes leben diese
installation ja genau von dem vertrauen
denn wenn sie es einmal verspielt haben
dann haben die alten probleme genau in
diesem sinne heller vielen dank für
dieses ausführliche gespräch gerne alles
gute bleiben sie so lang eure fragen und
kommentare und für die angeregte
diskussion bitte wie immer bleibt
sachlich und zivilisiert meistens
gelingt das ja auch wenn nicht dann
greifen wir rein
in diesem sinne freuen wir uns auf den
nächsten live stream mit euch und euren
fragen aber für heute machen wir den
deckel drauf und ich sage erstmal bleibt
gesund
[Musik]
und wenn euch der torque off fallen ab
und guckt doch mal hier rein da haben
wir mit dem virologen schmidt-chanasit
über den sinn und unsinn einer masken
pflicht gesprochen er hat eine ganz
andere meinung als herr lesch außerdem
gibt es hier ein video mit dem
faktencheck andré wolf wie man
verschwörungstheorien zu corona erkennen
kann außerdem habe in der playlist hier
und all unseren talks und videos und wie
immer passende ab unten liegt
[Musik]